lyon sort de l'estac aujourd'hui on va
tester plusieurs jeux sur locustes rift
1 y compris celui ci où il se passe à
peu près rien finalement
séméga fois ok le screamer audio assez
génial
bonjour comment allez vous 1 ainsi que
l'a été une sorte de d'orange avec des
yeux voilà allez salut à d'accord ok ça
se rapproche très bien tout va bien et
c'est vous qui faites ça je suppose
bande de banjo beach aaa alors blacks
vous savez pas d'humour et me fait
vraiment pas d'humour ça vous fait rire
ah c'est très drôle ça hein d'écraser
des gens comme ça à mon gars ok d'accord
[ __ ] s'intéresse cette merde
ok actuellement né dans l'océan et jeune
âge à une vitesse est un [ __ ] de
requins là bas c'est génial là pour coup
j'ai l'impression d'y être
oh elle m'a pas vu un baleine protège
moi non tu ne me vois pas un requin
[ __ ] les immenses qu'alain baleine
c'est bon elle m'a pris sous son aile je
risquais rien au maire mickaël donc là
on est vraiment au fin fond de l'océan
où il ya des bruits bizarres je tombé au
mauvais endroit c'est ça et si je vais
là dedans
[ __ ] mais sauf sérieux de foot
d'escrimeur dans l'océan mais c'est
cette zone est interdite par la loi ça
j'ai envie de rage quitte le jeu a pas
tout est petit toi tu me fait pas peur
allez allez ça va les petits car ça va
aller remets toi aller très bien
est-ce que ça c'est une cachette secrète
os ok d'accord à chalon l'impression de
pouvoir les le roi des google
je suis pas être est ce que je sais qui
est un passage secret ne mentez pas vous
êtes des menteurs salut de l'ensemble
des océans qu'est ce qui fait que ça la
met pas deux fois les américains vous
m'avez une fois vous m'aurez pas deux
fois donc je préfère vous le dire tout
cas au plus tard on était dans un
recueil pendant un instant salut à
tuchan un peu à peu la merde alors je
vais entrer là dedans
oh non on se l'est ce sont son petit
ventre bien rempli et ne voit pas [ __ ]
ils cherchent aux foires et où vous
cacher dans le sang [ __ ] il cherche
bien on morte mais qu il va t'acheter
des lunettes quoi si tu as besoin
d'aller au ras du sol à ce point pour
voir les proies ça pas du tout enfin
cache cache
allez viens de battre de tout ça cesse
viens non mais c'est une blague
c'est dans mes fait exprès la hune troll
vient rien je suis là voilà à la tum
avait raté en vrai c'est bien ce que je
dis ça car on a besoin de lui d'être
d'accord donc à sa part sur une danse ne
me demandez pas à quoi on est en train
de jouer j'en ai aucune idée
c'est juste que on y va
c'est un scribe heures soit aussi mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça au délà
mister bean qui nous fait des grimaces
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire une taille
pourquoi ses bras bol bordel ok faut le
regarder en fait c'est ça d'accord ok
oui ils font vidéo puisque c'est les
yeux devant les piles bouton sert à rien
j'ai co psy comme si quelqu'un comme si
quelqu'un te faire garder cette photo
que les mister bean cobain exige qu'ils
dessus juste n'importe quoi
actuellement on est sur jamal fonctionne
et je suis quelqu un et je danse même le
kuduro bon il sait pas très bien le
faire mais bon ça c'est bien fait je
crois vraiment que je suis dans mon
appart aussi ensemble deuxième étage où
c'est juste une pièce pour s'asseoir et
méditer voilà quelques espoirs dans
celle ci
ces locataires sur la langue bizarre
dans les pièces met juste de quoi
s'asseoir et rien d'autre a soit pour
regarder une porte à chaque fois ou
salut ma femme
comment va dessus ou la [ __ ] les
chelou un t shirt loose bah oui tu
échoues tu sais que ça ne la croit pas
fait la nana mais reste loin très bien
voilà donc c'est bien ce que je dis à
tout le monde te trouve bizarre venu
demander de me faire un petit et le gros
votre show ah bah si ça va la faire
craquer elle valait tarn
what i call girl bolt powell au plus
tard
oui je parle moi mieux au profil
je le savais un [ __ ] de robots des
débuts je t'avais repéré un ok on va se
cacher on sirois 86 3 1 ou alors tu fais
le coût de revient sur les terroirs ya
problème
et on s'enfuit pas donne moi ton argent
1 et ne se moque pas de montants requis
colis au [ __ ] mais répond ok d'accord
tout va bien c'est une sorte de
célébration puis je m'en allais me fais
pas la [ __ ]
bon c'est fini ok actuelle bordée sur
une simulation de poulets ya un
chronomètre et des calories il ya quoi
ici on cette soupe ah non non ok ok
québec
aulas ol aux yeux juste la fête à poulet
avec une moustache si génial au jeu suit
décédé je m'envole au ciel maintenant
faut aller en dehors au mont dieu ok
d'accord là des graines par terre c'est
génial il faut de l'eau la [ __ ]
léonard à aller loin ouais c'est ça
roule pas la queue entre les jambes
brad est ce qu'on va manger le renard ou
pire on va tenter un s'il te plaît jeune
renard sauvage l'honneur de te picorer
la queue merci rumeurs au très bien
apparemment la queue de renard n'a pas
suffi à remplir mon petit estomac de
poule
je suis pas bien cette [ __ ] de grands
chocs sont pleins de truc à manger là
dedans et les papillons venez jeunes
papillon je ne vais pas vous attend
aussi du poil ng moyen de faim quoi s'il
vous plaît il m'aura pas il m'aura pas
il n'aura pas une graine au passage a
alors non ne cache pas de fougères je te
vois un peu d'eau please yes weekend à
jan von arx mais il faut de l'eau mehal
renard mais il nous faut de l'eau non on
va tourner autour d'eux mais ils
affrontaient il a chanté allez au
tournant tourne à l'économie d'assumer
floride à signer
non tu ne mourra jamais je suis le roi
des poules
comment vas tu veux manger [ __ ] on a
calmé au merde
salut comment allez vous achetez achetez
oreilles allez ça ferait des toilettes
est maintenant un bain de foule pour le
roi des poules
oui très bien où tu vas manger un stade
devant même pas laissé une seconde de
répit et l'allégeance et ja fin de cette
petite vidéo sur divers ce jeu sur le
look du script j'espère que ça vous aura
plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo que je le sache on se retrouve
très bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo tu
vois tout le monde
décollage imminent ça
m
c'est
et